critics are questioning President Biden
over his many many trips to Delaware the
president has reportedly spent more than
one quarter of his term in Delaware
that's 174 days away from the White
House it's also 39 more days than
president Trump but his at this time in
his term more time out of the office
than all of his recent predecessors as
well and the first lady has reportedly
been working overtime to protect her
husband according to the New York Times
Dr Jill Biden has a lot of influence on
the president's decisions she even
helped vet White House officials Tammy
Bruce is a Fox News contributor she
joins us now what Acumen or or what a
life experience professionally do we
know that Dr Jill Biden has for vetting
White House officials well I think that
it's not about what they're going to do
for the country necessarily or how
they're going to do their job what she
can do is she understands what her
husband can do and what her husband's
capable of and what he needs so I think
any spouse could vet those individuals
in that fashion and that's what worries
me that this is about really just
protecting him as an individual and many
of us myself included thought she would
stop this from happening because she
would love her husband and not want his
reputation ruined but it seems as though
we'll remember a photograph early on she
was on Air Force One at the president's
desk I believe with his jacket on
looking at a binder of of you know
policies and things and it was like the
people were saying who got elected here
she was literally photographed in his
position so we've known that the
president is not necessarily as engaged
uh the fact is she is protecting him
specifically it means someone else
really is running the country and we've
had that question from the beginning are
we comfortable I guess the question then
becomes for voters if you should want to
run in 2024 is there a comfort zone for
a person who has never been elected to
to have that that's the issue here's
what's interesting to me about what you
said and it's spot on especially given
that picture that that I do recall why
wasn't that Kamala Harris we we actually
do have somebody to do that job exactly
she would be the vice president so was
this like uh what is this well from the
beginning clearly all of these were
political decisions uh and whether it's
because Kamala Harris did real damage to
him during that one debate about the
issue of bussing and racial segregation
well you know it's funny how quickly she
she pulled out of the race once that was
done and then she became the vice
president so we look those kinds of
choices are made all the time for
political reasons to get somebody out of
a race in order to protect yourself but
the fact of the matter is is that this
is something that you're absolutely
right no one would have minded we should
exceed the Vice President in a position
like that but for all this time we
haven't really even seen that that of
course was the beginning perhaps of the
division that maybe was there from the
beginning between her office and the
presidents well uh Dr Joe Biden is doing
everything right now she is putting
clothes on him as they're coming off
flights he's dropping his sunglasses
she's helping him with every aspect of
life the world sees that as well and
they know what's going on let's quickly
get to this a Wall Street Journal op-ed
by Bill mcgin argues Obama warned us
about Joe and and you remember what he
said on the eve of 2020 Iowa caucuses
political lobbed a grenade in Joe
Biden's Direction it was a story noting
that the former vice president was
trying to play the Obama card even
though Obama hadn't endorsed the man who
had served him Faithfully for eight
years the money he quote was don't don't
underestimate Joe's ability to expletive
things up real quick well you know
Barack Obama's the leader of the party
effectively he's has the most power in
the Republic in the Democratic party and
he could have stopped this from
happening but he didn't so he knew of
the weaknesses of this man who knew what
would occur perhaps he felt that Susan
Rice could run the country I don't know
but we've got this problem he could have
stopped it he didn't and that's what
everybody needs to know he says some
nice Obama's back but then again who
else do they have with his popularity
exactly no one he decimated that party
during his time and that's why thank you
Tammy hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else